el centro de la pequeña ciudad de cons
berg en el sureste de noruega fue
acordonado por completo por la policía
fue allí donde un hombre atacó armado
con arco y flechas a los transeúntes
provocando varias víctimas
[Música]
el sospechoso es un ciudadano danés de
37 años que reside en el país la policía
ya había investigado anteriormente al
hombre por problemas relacionados con la
radicalización no tenemos nada
registrado de él este 2021 pero si de
antes
los servicios de inteligencia noruego se
han puesto en alerta máxima aunque el
hombre habría actuado solo se pidió a
los residentes que se quedaran en sus
casas y se le dio permiso temporal de la
policía que trabajan normalmente sin
armas para portar pistolas
si esto está relacionado con el
terrorismo porque aún no sabemos si se
trata de un ataque político la policía
tendrá igual que investigar en muchos
países durante mucho tiempo los ataques
se han evitado por el trabajo de la
policía pero cuando se trata de un
perpetrador solitario es más
en el pasado noruega ya ha sido víctima
de ataques en particular por parte de
grupos de extrema derecha en 2011 anders
behring breivik mató a 77 personas en
2019 otro hombre disparó en una mezquita
en los últimos años también se han
frustrado varios planes de ataques
islamistas